so 14.8
inflation is where we hit in march of
1980 and as a result of that you tighten
monetary policy i remember it very well
you set an m1 target of 5.5
and as a result of that
uh interest rates went up to 20 percent
more than you ever expected
and when you when you tighten monetary
policy like that
it drove the unemployment rate up
to 10 percent
and it
caused
the worst downturn in that period of
time since the great depression and you
held tight in that there were protests
there was anger
and you held tight in that and you
followed it through
and as a result of that
you broke the back of inflation and in
1983
that inflation rate went down to three
percent inflation at that time and we
began a decade
of prosperity of strong growth with low
inflation they may not remember the
atmosphere as was experienced the
inflation rate had gone up
for more than a decade there were kind
of feeble efforts to deal with it during
the ford administration they handed out
buttons whip inflation now but it had no
had more buttons than policy
and there was always this conflict
which always exists don't tighten
monetary policy too far you'll get some
unemployment
so we want to decade that way and we got
more
inflation and more unemployment
and when i took over
the federal reserve
at the end of carter's administration
president carter was totally frustrated
because he seemed to be unable to take
any initiative anyway
because all this inflation was
backfiring running he couldn't do
anything in the budget he couldn't do
anything on energy all these things he
would have liked to have
seemed to be stalled by
this fear of inflation it was very real
at that time
and so he asked me to become chairman of
the federal reserve well
it was obvious that existing policies
weren't working
and actually i was in the federal
reserve before that voting against some
of those policies
but i decided we had to change an
approach and we've got to
stop worrying about increasing
unemployment
at any time
we've got to deal with this inflation or
it's going to get worse and worse
because it was accelerating when they
got close to 15 annual rate
and if we pussy-footed much longer we're
going to be 20
and people were really fearful about the
stability of the country
so we did tighten it took a long while
actually for the
unemployment rate to go up it was very
stubborn and the inflation rate was very
stubborn
and we made
one or two false moves we had to take
back it looked a little longer than we
thought but i saw no other way to
approach this
other than
kind of a bulldog biting at it
straight out and i got plenty worried in
82 when we
did begin getting unemployment
the damn inflation rate wasn't coming
down and the money supply wasn't
coming down the way we wanted
but i felt we were stuck we
we couldn't back off
all the effort we were making
would be for naught
fortunately by
the summer of 82
things the money spliking down
inflation rate became coming down
we had a recession but by the end of the
year it looked like the recession could
be over
or at least stopped getting worse and
it ended pretty quickly
but it took that last
year of
sticking with it
that i think was necessary to do the job